if you are looking forward to the Battle
Star Galactica movie and reboot I have
some good news and some bad news welcome
to sidere your scii TV and Movie Channel
morning sir good morning Starbucks what
are you here nothing about the rain grab
your gun and bring in the cat boom boom
[Music]
boom should we go good news or bad news
first let's go good news so six months
ago I told you guys in a video that
plans for a battl Star Galactica
rebooted movie a movie that was probably
going to be a remake of the original
story and Sam esmail's planned TV reboot
that was going to be in Cannon with
Ronald D Moore's Battle Star Galactica
series were basically dead they were
both put on the back burner and it
didn't look like there was much chance
we were going to be getting either
project
here morning
here nothing but the rain and grab your
gun and bring the cat in I answer sir
coming home however now the writers have
returned to work and it looks like the
actors are about to follow suit it's
time to get a little bit of an update is
that still the case well first of all
the good news
the TV series by Sam esmail looks like
it is back on track Sam esmail has
released a statement during an interview
basically saying he has been able to
have a look at what's going on with the
project the scripts are coming along
nicely he's really happy with the
outline of where they're going and it
looks like everything is coming up Rosy
now he did interestingly say in that
interview that he can't speak for the
movie now I found that very interesting
because when they've spoken about the
movie before before Sam asmail did say
that they were in Step together that
there were lots of conversations between
the two production companies and that
they were hoping to make these two
projects sort of in sync with each other
in some way so the fact that he hasn't
been able to say much well I'm afraid
that's going to be leaning into the bad
news but we'll come to that in a minute
first of all what can we expect from the
series so I've been told a couple of
interesting facts one of the things I'm
most looking forward to is something
that Sam Ismail talked about a little
while ago that there was going to be an
epic battle Midway through this season
the plan was to drop these three
episodes at the same time that these
episodes would show three different
perspectives of the same battle and that
basically Sam asil was talking about how
exciting is that with a platform like a
streaming service on peacock where this
TV show is planned to go you can do
things like that you can drop episodes
in an order and in a way that makes
sense to the audience so when you get
one major event like an epic battle like
that but you want to show that battle
from three different sides you can drop
those three episodes together that's
what works for the audience that what
works for the story I think that's going
to be really interesting I have also
heard an unconfirmed rumor now this is
very much in the rumor category but
apparently this story might actually be
a prequel based after kapra before battl
Star Galactica this series would be
based around the original human sylon
War we would get to see the launch of
the battl Star Galactica we would get to
see why the Battlestar Galactica became
such a famous warship and then why in
Ronald De Moore's series why her being
decommissioned is such a big deal for
people why they are turning her into a
museum how did she earn her Stripes now
I actually think that's a really inter
story line because if you are going to
have Battle Star Galactica and it's
going to be in Universe with Ronald De
Mo's version it really can't follow the
battle side Galactica series I don't
think sensibly anyway you have to do
something that's before now obviously
there's going to be quite a long period
between the original sylon War and the
second sylon war that nothing really
happened but the launch of the battar
Galactica and her exploits in the
original conflict now that is something
I would like to see now again this is
unconfirmed it is a rumor I've heard it
basically third hand so we have to take
that with a pinch of salt but if true
that could be pretty cool now nearly two
years ago Simon kingberg started talking
about his plans for a battl Star
Galactica reboot now they talked about
how this would actually share the same
universe with Sam esma's reboot but in
some ways it was going to be a remake
now those two things obviously don't sit
side by side and there is a link to the
story in the description because Sam
Ismail talked about this being in Cannon
with Ronald
deore but Simon kingberg talks about
this being a remake of the original
story that doesn't make sense unless
instead of a remake it is actually just
a retelling of the original syon
conflict now that might make sense even
though I'm not really sure about the way
Simon King burgers described that
however the movie was always planned to
be in step and in sync and in Universe
with the series That Then followed but
it's still stuck in development hell
there is no news that this is going to
be moving forward it was supposed to
have begun filming this summer but
obviously the strikes have really put a
poo poo on that and all of my sources
are telling me that right now as we
stand it is not moving forwards the fact
that Sam Asma has declined to talk about
it really does tell you everything you
need to know anyway but speaking to
several people there are no plans to
push forwards with it right now one
Insider's opinion is that they're
probably going to push forward with the
series see how it's received and then
maybe make a decision on the movie so
for now it's a little bit of a waiting
game but it is just one of those
projects that might just get stuck in
development hell for an eternity
Purgatory if you will and I'm 5050
whether we're ever going to see it
so that's some good news and some bad
news for the Battlestar Galactica fans
but guys what do you think is this a
project that you'd rather see in a
series anyway and with the changing face
of Cinema is it maybe a bit risky for
the producers to even take a project
like this to the cinema we all know that
it's very unpredictable at the moment in
the box office what do you think get
into the comments if you are new to the
channel like subscribe hit the Bell
notification it really helps us out you
know you want to
and please go over to patreon.com citre
where you get to see most of our new
videos first and for small contribution
each month that really supports Channel
you get a free gift and you get to see
all these videos first and without the
adverts can't say furer than that also
go to
s.o. which is our dedicated website
where we do articles based on most of
our videos and we try to add a little
bit more detail for you to digest go
check it out as always please stay safe
and I'll see you next time
[Music]